There were so many bloopers and gags produced
in The Office that they could almost make up
their own show. Some of those cut gags
were even funnier than the final version
of the scene. Here is the best of those
character-breaking, line-fumbling moments.
Now that he's broken up with Jan, Michael
is pitifully lonely and desperate enough to
become borderline obsessed with the
model in an office supply catalog.
Desperate for companionship before
he gets too old and can't have kids,
Michael demands his subordinates each write down
the name of a single woman they know that he could
go on a date with. In the original scene, after a
whole afternoon of Michael's self-pitying antics,
Pam relents and says she has someone for
him: her poor, unsuspecting landlady.
"Michael?"
"Uh."
"Are you Michael Scott?"
The blooper during this scene came in
the form of a poorly delivered line.
"Is — Is she hot? That was such a bad take!"
Ryan Howard, introduced to us in the
pilot episode as a mild-mannered temp,
has risen to the rank of corporate VP
by the beginning of season four. When he
reintroduces himself to "his favorite branch" in
Scranton, neither his five o'clock shadow nor his
Bluetooth nor his new, expensive suit succeed in
getting anyone to respect him the way he wants.
The people who don't like him continue not
liking him, and the people who do won't stop
treating him like he's still the adorable little
office temp that everyone likes to pick on.
In the original scene, Ryan snaps and
admonishes Michael in front of the office.
"I am your boss now. You're gonna have to
treat me the same way you treated Jan."
In the blooper, Steve Carrell and Brian
Baumgartner imitated him, and he began laughing.
"But you--"
After he finished laughing, BJ apologized.
"I'm really sorry I broke, that was too good."
This episode begins with a despondent Phyllis
telling her coworkers that she was flashed by
a man in a trench coat after she stopped to
help him with directions in the parking lot.
Michael goes back and forth between making crass,
inappropriate jokes and trying to host a
series of women's appreciation seminars
and events for which, as Jim points out,
he is completely unqualified to manage.
"I'd like to apologise for all of the men
who thought this was a laughing matter."
Meanwhile, Dwight announces the creation
of a very serious indeed anti-flashing
task force that will be run entirely by
him, even though he has no clue how to
investigate a crime and local police are
already on the job. While explaining the
task force to his coworkers, he refers to
Phyllis as "phallus" before apologizing.
"Phyllis, sorry. I've got penises on the brain."
"Back to work everybody."
Naturally, a scene like this would be
hard to get through with a straight face.
The cast tried it multiple times,
breaking constantly. At one point,
Rainn Wilson, who played Dwight, tried
to muscle through and complete the scene.
"That is a risk that we have to— No,
no, no, I know what you're saying."
"Why do you— Why do you keep going?"
With Michael and Pam out giving sales training
presentations to the other regional branches,
Jim and Dwight are in charge of the office.
Things immediately take a turn for the worse when
they realize they've forgotten Kelly's birthday.
Kelly is angry, and when Dwight stands
up for Jim, she grows even angrier.
"Yeah, screw you, beet farmer! I don't
forget your birthday. I would never do that."
"Guys, Guys, Guys."
Jim tries to salvage the situation
before Dwight yells back and makes it
worse by promising her a cake
and a party that afternoon.
It's probably not that surprising that a scene
like this might've been a little too much fun
to shoot. In other takes, every time John
Krasinski steps in to lower the temperature,
Rainn Wilson shoots him a shocked, wide-eyed look.
"Hey! Guys. C—"
"Stop doing that. It makes no sense."
By the third failure, they're all a little bit
frustrated, but still having plenty of fun.
At the beginning of the fifth season, the Scranton
branch participates in a company-wide
weight loss competition. Naturally,
things go astray. Kelly starves herself and
tries to buy a tapeworm from Creed. Dwight,
after insulting several of his coworkers for
their weight, tricks Phyllis into going on a
non-existent sales call, only to abandon her,
forcing her to burn calories on her walk back.
"There was no client.
Dwight drove me to an abandoned warehouse
five miles away and pushed me out of the car.”
Holly sets up an HR meeting to address the
madness, but Michael ruins it by donning a
semi-deflated sumo suit and appearing
in character as "Michael Klump,"
an insulting "celebration" of overweight people.
"This big, fat pig is beautiful."
The original scene is an Office classic,
but the gag version is even better.
"Well, hello everybodyyyy."
Carrell had to try multiple takes before
everyone was able to hold in their laughter.
An excited Andy and a not-so-excited
Angela have decided, at her insistence,
to book Schrute Farms as their wedding venue, and
are planning a lunch break trip to check it out.
Problem is, proprietor Dwight doesn't
know how to give acceptable directions.
"Walk until you hear the beehive."
When Andy brings this up, Dwight insists
the directions are perfectly normal.
"How could it be more clear?"
In the bloopers from this scene, nobody
can keep a straight face as Ed Helms
tries out some bizarre, obviously ad-libbed lines.
"If you are attacked by territorial crows—"
It clearly took quite a few
tries to get a usable take.
Pam is pregnant with her and Jim's first child,
but she's resisting everyone's attempts to get
her to the hospital. If you ask her, she'd say she
wants to wait until after midnight for insurance
purposes, but the reality is that she's scared
of going into labor and wants to drag it out.
Jim is slowly losing it trying to get her
to the hospital, and at one point relies
on Michael to tell him when her contractions
start coming every five minutes. When he finds
out they're now coming every two minutes, he
yells at Michael for not informing him earlier.
"We waited too long. Two minutes doesn't
do us any good. Well, what happened to four
and three minutes?!"
In other takes, the actors struggled to
make it through this scene without cracking.
"No, what—"
"You gotta hold it together, okay?"
The kickoff to season 4 is Meredith ending
up hospitalized after Michael hits her with
his car in the parking lot. She has a minor
pelvic fracture and gets a rabies shot after
the doctor finds out she might've been bitten
by a bat when one was trapped in the office
during the previous season. This prompts
a guilt-stricken Michael to launch a "Fun
Run" race for the rabies cure, despite the fact
that Meredith likely doesn't have rabies — and,
as Jim pointed out, it's already been
cured. While he's organizing all that,
Pam rallies the coworkers for a lunch break
carpool to visit Meredith in the hospital.
In a scene that didn't make the final cut,
Steve Carrell can't get his line right.
When Jenna Fischer tells everyone, quote, "Okay,
we're leaving for the hospital at one," Carrell is
supposed to respond with, quote, "like a freedom
tree?" Instead, he trips all over the line.
"Okay, so, we're all leaving
for the hospital at 1 o'clock."
"Yes, so fab, fruh-freedom tree."
"I can take three—"
In season 7, Jim, Dwight, and even Michael,
all seasoned and talented salesmen,
lose a major potential client to
rival traveling rep Danny Cordray,
of Osprey Paper. Michael promptly calls
the sales team to a brainstorming session
upon returning to the office, and asks
everyone for ideas to outmaneuver Cordray.
"We sell better."
Michael mistakes Stanley's sarcasm
for indifference, tells him to leave,
and suggests he has diabetes. Stanley insists
he doesn't have diabetes and would like to stay,
for once, as Cordray affected his
paycheck, but he eventually leaves.
"See? I could tell by the sound you made when
you stood up that you have— Okay, yes Phillis?"
That scene took several tries to nail. Initially,
when Michael said his last line to Stanley,
every cast member in the room lost it.
"See, just the noise you made
when you stood up, I could—”
One of the major storylines of season three
was the merging of the defunct Stamford,
Connecticut branch with the one in Scranton.
Martin, one of the Stamford transplants,
is a former convict who'd been briefly imprisoned
for insider trading, long before starting his
career with Dunder Mifflin. Once he finds out
about this, Michael tries awkwardly defending
Martin, simply because he's Black and
Michael is worried about stereotypes.
"But I just want to declare publicly
that I trust him completely."
Then, when his subordinates start inquiring about
prison and pretending to wish they were in it,
Michael sees Martin as a threat
to office morale and his "fun
boss" shtick. In one scene,
Michael barges into the break room,
where Martin is casually explaining
his prison time to his new coworkers.
"Been a lot of fun talk about prison
today, but I'm here to scare you straight."
In the bloopers, not knowing the
camera was rolling, a crew member
audibly starts talking in the background,
forcing everyone to reset for a new take.
"We're rolling, Alyssa."
"Right, how are ya?"
"I thought somebody just said 'Mel.'"
In another take, Steve Carrell is delivering lines
in his iconic purple bandana
when the group begins laughing.
"Where did you pinch him?"
Dunder Mifflin Infinity, Ryan Howard's new
paper-buying online portal that he hopes will
modernize the ailing company, is going live.
To celebrate, the office decides to order some
pizza for a branch party. Michael comes out of his
office to announce that hot food is on the way.
"Good news."
"We get to go home?"
In a different take, Leslie David Baker
doesn't just say that line — he shouts it,
joyously, wide-eyed, throwing his hands
into the air and leaning back in his seat.
"I have some good news."
"We get to go home!"
This prompts Steve Carrell, followed quickly by
the entire cast, to break into uncontrollable
laughter. Leslie himself is laughing harder than
anyone. John Krasinski is howling so hard he holds
his hands over his face. If you don't at least
crack up watching this, you may be dead inside.
If you're watching a video about The Office,
you've almost certainly seen what's arguably
its greatest episode: Season 4's Dinner Party.
Michael and his borderline psychotic girlfriend
and former boss, Jan, host an after-work
get-together at their condo with Jim, Pam,
Andy, Angela, Dwight, and Dwight's former
babysitter, who he brought as a date.
The episode, in which Michael and Jan's
relationship unravels before the eyes of
their squirming guests over the course of
an evening filled with awkward house tours,
failed business pitches, games that nobody
likes, a screaming match about having kids,
passive-aggressive arguments between the hosts,
a very late meal that both Pam and Michael think
Jan has poisoned, and much more, is a triumph
of cringe comedy that's never been matched.
"Michael and Jan seem to be
playing their own separate game,
and it's called, 'Let's see how
uncomfortable we can make our guests.'"
The blooper reel is even more entertaining.
The episode was famously hard to shoot because
everyone in it simply could not stop
laughing long enough to get good takes.
In one take, Steve Carrell talks about Michael's
tiny plasma screen TV before saying, quote,
"Right over here, Jim" to John Krasinski.
"I guess what surround sounds means
is that— Right over here, Jim."
Co-writer Lee Eisenberg said,
"There's nothing more satisfying than having Steve
Carell barely able to get through his lines."
"Oh, Jesus, this is terrible.
We'll never finish this episode."
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper
videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.